[Music]
all right let's go to brian in evanston
this thing's just gonna get off the
rails before we get going what's up
brian
hey how's it going what's up b money
good dude you
good it's uh good to talk to you again
you too man again have we talked before
yeah yeah
you actually named uh the episode after
my thing
oh so quick insider baseball i don't
ever name any of the episodes that's
pretty cool that's kelly's job
very cool somebody did yeah there you go
hey so what's up man
hey hold on what did we talk about last
time
uh my about my ex-wife and how she's an
emotional terrorist
and uh it was i think it was back in
april so it was quite a while ago
every i don't quite remember it but
everyone in the booth was like oh yeah
we remember brian all right
so welcome back brian it's good to see
you again
yeah uh thanks for having me um
yeah so my my question was like i'm kind
of frustrated with my wife and
and i'm trying to keep it from turning
into resentment from her okay this is
your current wife
yeah yeah my current wife okay and uh
you know she's she's been going to
school to get her bachelor's degree
and uh you know it's taken her 10 years
and you know she started with an
associates okay and you know she's
racked up a bunch of student loan debt
and uh you know now she's she's at the
end here and and you know she keeps
failing this test she has to take
and every time it's like 150 bucks
and i mean uh
i mean i don't think she's stupid for
sure like she's smart
i just don't understand why she keeps
failing it
and uh
you know i i'm almost starting to resent
her for it because i mean it's like i'm
financing
her dreams while i have to work a job
that i really don't like
just so we can pay the bills you know
uh
i'm trying to think of where to start
so right out of the gate you already
resent her dude you don't like her
you're annoyed by her and she pisses you
off let's just cut to it like yeah let's
be honest she does
um
that's a tough place to be
um what is she going to school for
what's taken 10 years to get 60 credit
hours
early childhood development
um
and uh
you know
there's no exit test for for so it's
for certification it's called the praxis
test okay
yeah what does she want to do
she wants to you know uh she wants to
work with special ed kids
but uh you know with that degree with
her degree she could go you know work up
to like uh teach up to like third grade
i think so sh let me just be real clear
she has no interest in doing this
she hasn't
i would hope she does she this is like
her dream
it's absolutely not 100 it's not
i guarantee you it's not
here's how i know here's how i know
um and dude you're gonna have to chill
out and i know you're pissed off but you
have to chill out
um yeah
if this was her dream she would have
done 60 hours in 18 months
there would there's a
year around if when you're around people
who are obsessive
about a dream the thing that they really
want to do
they make it happen
they don't take a decade to get 60 hours
and you're talking to a guy they got two
phds and had kids and i was working a
full-time job and i was married i was
obsessed right yeah we got we got four
kids she works at the school right now
as a para educator or whatever and
i know dude can you just hear your voice
you don't like her
i don't like what she's doing no no you
don't like her
why
why i like to think that i like her at
least
i would too she you're she's the mother
of your kids four years and all this
is it something
i feel like i'm a cash cow
you're her husband man i feel like
yeah but i feel like i'm just her cash
cow because i mean you know she's
she's going through all the schooling
costing a bunch of money and like she
like she didn't work all summer
and you know we've been doing the dave
ramsey thing trying to pay off debt she
didn't want to get a job this whole
summer
and she doesn't make any money while
she's while she's off
and you know so i've been i've been
supporting the family for three months
now and and you know
it's just it's frustrating me
pretty bad and and i can't even tell her
about it because then she'll start
crying and and uh you know because uh
she'll shut down which like she'll just
clam right up
dude i'm claiming right up now talking
to you
why
because man you're coming at me like i
did something like your whole your whole
ain't you you are so full of anger
i can hear it in you man
and the way you just come
you're not interested in a discussion or
hey what's next
it'd say i've got to get this out and
let me be honest it's okay to do that
it's super okay right i'm not gonna hurt
my feelings
um
but i absolutely can see you being a lot
my question for you is this this is not
the ultimate issue
there's something beneath this or
beneath that and here's let me throw a
couple of ideas out there number one
you got how old your your oldest kid
15 15 and what's your youngest
uh should be five next month okay
so
you've got four kids things are chaotic
bills are very very tight you found
yourself in a mess you're um with a 15
year old all the way down to a
five-year-old i'm just guessing here
this is most couples this doesn't have
to be you your sex life screwed up your
time alone with your wife is screwed up
your friends are screwed up like it's
just you're just running and running and
running
and whenever we're running running and
running we start looking for who's not
doing their right and so it becomes this
woe is me woe is me kind of thing
um that could be one of them
it could be that you don't like who
you've become
and i'm gonna go right i don't know what
the deal is but there's something
beneath the thing what is the thing
beneath the thing
i'm not attracted to my wife anymore i
think she's lazy i don't like her
character like what is the thing beneath
the thing
because this is
it's been going on for 10 years brother
and so
it would have boiled up before now is
what i'm saying
i guess maybe maybe i don't like her
character i don't like her i don't
really like her work ethic
she you know she almost seems like she
just doesn't care about uh anything who
takes care of these four kids
well uh we we you know she's at home
with them right now just because she's
uh uh you know it's summer vacation and
uh
but they'll be in school
you know i mean i'm home every night uh
you know even though i'm a truck driver
but
you know i'm there with her
but like you know she's just sitting
around all day watching reality tv and
crap
and uh you know
have you ever stayed at home with four
kids
yeah
yeah i've done that and there's just
nothing going on
she just sitting around well
well yeah i mean she's you know she's
just sitting around uh you know the kids
are tearing the house apart and
you know it's not necessarily that i
need her to i want her to clean up you
know like the house has to be immaculate
and dinner has to be on the table when i
get home but
you know i mean like uh she's you know
it just doesn't seem like she's putting
forth any effort
uh like it's almost like she just
doesn't care i mean like
we don't even think the same about money
we you know she she sees
like 500 bucks in our account and and i
see no money
and you know and we can't even get we
can't even be on the same page about
that
why you know it's like we're living two
separate lives that's that's it right
there
that's it right there well that's
i mean i don't know how i'm gonna i
don't know how i can because if i if i
try to
give her
maybe some advice i i probably do come
off as overbearing and arrogant 100
and
yeah and and you know but like she said
she's telling me well why is your way
the right way
that's a very fair question
it's a fair question
but i i don't think she's ever uh she's
always had a safety net i don't think
she's ever been desperate
like i have she's your wife what's the
matter with you
dude what do you mean she's my wife what
does that have to do with it
i don't ever
ever i am my wife's safety net
well i and she's mine
i don't ever want my wife to have to
feel desperate what are you talking
about
i'm just saying in her younger years
she's never had to feel desperate like
like with money you know
i i i'm her safety net i i i go out work
70 hours a week and
you know i mean i i take care of them
i don't want her to feel desperate now
but i'm just saying she never did and
that's why i think that's why she feels
that like money is not important or
something
you know
i don't know i am arrogant and and i
have a big ego i can admit that so
uh
here's what it sounds like dude can i be
honest with you
it sounds like you are real real
freaking lonely
sounds like you are
real lonely
and i'm surrounded by people that's
exactly right
and you're drowning yes right on a boat
full of people
and
it was a revelation to me
when i learned that
male depression
often male loneliness male depression
often
comes out
with volume with anger with you need to
fix fill in the blank
and anytime i'm sitting with somebody
like i am with you right now
who is who is this much disdain for his
wife
and yes you could say i love her if
somebody tried to come in the house i'd
fight them all yes you you could do the
willam william wallace stuff but you
don't like her you have disdain for her
and that's not like just my wife but
like
you wouldn't marry this person again
if you knew them and
that circles back in this world to you
and quite unfortunately she's on the
phone so you have her call me one day
and i talk to her about all of her soap
opera watching and her bon-bon eating
which i i take issue with that's a whole
other call
what do you need man
i don't know what do you need you do you
do man what do you need
what's scaring you i i feel like i feel
like she doesn't no no no good talking
about her
what scares you okay
uh
i i guess being completely alone with no
people around me or something
uh
that that that scares me being divorced
again
hey you you are real real close to that
and you know that
yeah have you started talking to
somebody else
about divorce no i don't like i don't
have no no no no not about divorce
is is that
are you talking to somebody else are you
seeing somebody else are you texting
somebody else
oh no no no no okay no i'm no cheater
okay
um yeah this thing's dangerous to
dangerously close to getting off the
rails
but again you've been down this road you
know that
what scares you
are you scared about money man are you
scared about not having enough are you
scared about your kids
are you scared about the world what are
you scared about
i'm scared about never ever making
enough money
and she and you know i'm okay
stop right there what can you do about
that
i don't know
make more money i suppose
have you i i don't
have you ever sat down with your wife
and said i'm scared
yeah
and she just said i don't care and then
move over uh
real housewives of atlanta's coming on
yeah she says we're fine like why are
you scared we're fine
is she right you know and
not well i mean maybe it to a point
but you know like i i don't feel like
we're fine and i feel like once you get
to the point where you're fine and you
don't have this anxiety
then then you're you're you're going to
end up like you know
losing losing everything in the end
why why do you think that man
i don't know maybe
i know i'm i'm pretty pessimistic i like
to think of myself as a realist but
um you know i just i just feel like if
i'm not
anxious about you know getting the
mortgage paid then the mortgage won't
get paid have you ever missed a payment
you know
no okay so the data tells me you're a
guy that pays his bills
yeah
and
you're also telling me you're a guy
who's on a plan to get out of debt
you are
yeah but i'll tell you as a guy that
nearly burned my wife to the ground
with my anxiety
and my oh yeah but this could happen
what about this what about this and what
about this
and i had an emergency fund for our
emergency fund
and
i wouldn't take vacations for a decade
so that i could pay this off so i could
pay that off
and eventually my wife said i don't want
this life
yes we make here here ultimately brother
here was the line that that was the
bellwether line for me and it wasn't
from my wife it was from my buddy and i
came to find out that she had talked to
him and said i'm worried about john
and the line he gave me because we were
talking about money he's a banker he's a
savant
and we were talking about this and what
about the dollar and then what happens
here and how much do i need saved and
then what about the investment here and
i'm gonna put this in
and finally he said dude i don't have a
meteorite plan
i said what does that mean
and he said i got
like i'm saving money i'm trying to pay
off my debts and all that but
dude if the dollar implodes and we're
trading gold and coffee i'll deal with
that when we get there because i'm gonna
have to shoot my neighbor's dog for food
and what i would tell you is you have a
plan
what you don't have
is the skill set to be an engaged father
you do not have the skill set to be an
engaged loving present husband those are
tools and skills you don't have
and until you decide i want to get those
your body feels like it's on fire every
time you're around them and it gets
pushed off into proxy things like money
and if you guys got a million dollars
today within a month it would be about
something else how clean the house is
and then you hire a maid and then within
a month it would be about something else
your body's going to continue to find
something to blame to heal the internal
to put a band-aid over that internal
chaos which is relationship
and until you are enough of a brave
courageous man which i'm hoping this
phone call is that
to say
i am scared of being alone
i'm scared of my 15 year old son or
daughter looking at me and saying i
don't like being around that guy
or a five-year-old that would rather
play video game than be engaged with his
old man
then you say i don't have enough i don't
have the skills the tools i don't know
how to do this and i'm gonna go learn
those skills and tools and i'll tell you
right now you can turn all that around
that's where that's where we are
along the way
you will have to address your
conversation with your wife but that's
not where you start brother you start in
the mirror
and you work too hard and you love too
deeply to feel this alone
is that fair
yeah yeah
i just don't know where to start i don't
know how to do that
i feel like i'm lying to myself you know
you are
you are
you are and here's the other thing this
is it's as common thing with men myself
included here right
is
i'm not i i don't know how to i don't
know how to
do dad i'm not good at it
and when i tried early on my wife was
like what are you doing that's how you
do a diaper that no you got to warm the
bottle up to this not to that and you
can't put that in the microwave what do
you
and i found myself early on i was better
at work than i was at home so i just
started spending time there because
that's where i was good at what i did
and i felt like i could help there
and you've probably heard me talk about
the show it was just this this year that
my wife looked at me with her hands on
my face and said john we have enough
we need you
and then i thought oh crap i don't know
how to do that
yeah see what i'm saying
yeah
so it sounds like your wife has not
checked out of
uh it's not lazy it sounds like she's
she's
she quit
because you're probably a lot
[Music]
and my guess is she doesn't have a path
to victory with you
tell me i'm wrong you could say delon
you're full crap you're wrong
no i think you're i think you're right
but if she got her degree right now and
she went and got a job
she may have awareness that there's you
may not think i'm doing anything but
somebody the laundry of four kids plus a
a a driver has to get done
and this has to get done and that has to
get done all these things have to get
done the house will still move on
and
i'm gonna go make forty thousand and
within a few months my husband brian's
gonna ask me why aren't you making 50.
and why aren't you making 60. like i'm
just gonna sit here i'm out
and again i may be way out to lunch on
that dude
i would like to think that you know her
making 40 grand would be a big help
uh
would it i don't know i it seems like
well yeah i mean i like i'm almost
obsessed with paying off debt
and it's like she doesn't care i feel
like i'm dragging her to get to you know
to pay off debt yeah
and i
maybe i'm not i
you might you might actually be but what
i'm going to tell you is you're you're
going to not only not pay off your debt
by doing that you're going to lose your
marriage too
and at some point you'll have to come
together because the whole point of
doing something together like this
the reason that you pay off debt with
somebody else is because it forces you
to the table to say who do we want to
become
who do we want to be where we want to go
and let's do the things that we need to
do to get there
and that often not always not almost
even often
sometimes it results in people need to
go get counseling because i know i want
to lose 100 pounds and i know that it's
diet and exercise for some reason i
can't stop and i need to go get some
help i need to talk to somebody i need
to do this i do that i'm i'm the exact
same way i got to i have a coach right
now i got a counselor right like i got
people that help me do my stuff and i do
this for a living i know the answers but
i gotta i gotta have some more tools
right
um
is your 15 year old a boy girl
she's a girl
tell me about your relationship with her
well she i'm not 100 sure she likes me
um hold on say that in a more honest way
i think she hates me
i think her mother turned her turned her
against me okay she tried to commit
suicide twice in my house okay i
admitted her twice to a uh
mental institution uh to get treatment
and uh you know she she actually wrote a
letter to me
attacking me
and uh you know blaming me for all of
her problems and the therapist that she
was seeing actually said that she
attacked me because she felt safe with
me
or some crap like that
i didn't believe her the therapist uh
and
she actually had a one-on-one session
with me because apparently i was really
agitated
but uh brian
she's put she's been through a lot way
more than what any kid should be
you know who else has been through a lot
you
who
oh
yeah brian your daughter tried to die
twice
and she blamed you for it
and by the way your therapist was
probably right
how old was she
oh she was uh 12
and she tried it twice within six months
you know what we don't let 12 year olds
do we don't let them drive
we don't let them buy guns or beer
because they're kids
you know and as much as what she said
hurt you deeply you did not fail that 12
year old girl in fact you're her
lifeline
and 12 year olds say crazy things i have
a 12 year old now
and they do crazy things because they're
12.
but you're not a crappy dad
you didn't fail your kid you didn't
break your kid
well
i mean i i failed her when she was six
really
you know her one of her mom's boyfriends
assaulted her for two years under her
nose and
that was pretty bad did you know that
i didn't find out until my ex-wife
called me and said we're heading over to
the hospital because we got to do a rape
kit on kylie and i'm like
then you didn't fail your daughter did
you show up
i was there yeah
then you were there with her in the fire
my brother
listen
until you let brian off the hook
everything's gonna feel like it's on
fire
yeah
i thought i thought about this call you
don't like uh your wife and that may be
true
um
you don't like brian i think i don't i
think i hate myself i don't think so i
know so
yeah
and that's gotta stop because you're a
good dad
you're dad filled with rage and if my
little i have a six-year-old little girl
and if i found out she'd been sexually
assaulted
i would be filled with rage too to the
point that i couldn't breathe and i
couldn't see
okay
and if one of my if my 12 year old tried
to hurt himself and blame me for it i
would be sick and disgusted and i could
call myself a failure your responses
have been right but that doesn't mean
they're true
yeah
yeah i guess
no i don't guess i don't guess
i'm telling you have i ever lied to you
yet
no no
no i mean i just i feel like a pretty
bad dad exactly
and the way most men deal with i feel
pretty bad is i got to blame somebody
else because i don't have the tools to
look in the mirror and say whoa what
happened
so you think i'm throwing all that crap
on my wife i'm almost guaranteeing you
are or you're creating a home that makes
it hard to win in
i don't know your knee i don't know how
i can meet your needs to a way where you
will be at peace because you have no
peace you have no capacity for peace and
so when i try to meet your needs
then it comes out somewhere else and
somewhere else and somewhere else and at
some point i'm out
i'm out cause i can't i can't i can't
it's like playing a baseball game in the
and there's no strike zone they just
keep calling strikes and you don't know
where the like i'm not gonna i'm just
quit batting i don't know what we're
doing here
now if your wife was on the phone with
me
i would
be having a hard conversation with her
but she's not and ultimately at the end
of the day
you cannot control her behavior
you can't control what she does what she
doesn't do the fact that she's failing
exams she's feeling a test that she's
taking 10 years to do something that was
really
uh one to two years at most of a project
right
you can't you can't fix any of that
stuff
and yelling and screaming and being
pissed off i just sends people into
fight or flight and there's not a lot of
accomplishment that comes on the back
end of that
what you
need i don't yell and scream at her
i know dude but you're like i don't want
to stress her out even more for the next
test you know i know i know but dude you
know what makes it even
me and you are more similar than than
you think
and you know what my superpower was i
never ever ever yell when i'm pissed
never
but dude i can be really violent with my
silence
my silence can fill up a room
it's a nuclear reactor energy and my
kids know to back out my wife knows to
not engage and then i can be righteous
and have all the indignation the world
be like
i didn't say anything what oh
everybody's hate's dad because i'm so
tired because i've been working my butt
off right
no i knew exactly what i was doing
in fact if i yell people can point at me
and go that guy's crazy but if i'm a
nuclear reactor you know what they do
they go in the mirror and think they're
crazy
yeah
sort of like manipulation almost kind of
so here's the here's your path forward
my brother okay
path number one is
you're gonna have to write brian
the brian that nine years ago
found out that somebody sexually
assaulted his daughter
you're gonna have to write that brian
thank you letter and say thank you for
showing up and doing the best you could
in the single most nightmare situation i
can
it's imagine bad it is
and you're gonna have to write the brian
of three years ago four years ago
another letter
that says you are such a good father
that you're the only one that a spun out
terrified terrified little 12 year old
child
could throw a dart at
because even she was wise enough to know
that mom's too reactive i can't i can't
mom's not safe
and you need to write that guy note that
says thank you for loving your daughter
even though that hurt
yeah and then you're gonna have to go
sit down with your wife and say i'm
sorry
i've been scared for 10 years
i haven't liked myself for 10 years i've
been walking around with stories in my
head for 10 years
i'm anxious
i'm alone
and i need you to hear me say here's a
couple things i'm really scared about
i'm scared about
ending up completely alone i'm scared
about not having enough money for these
kids
i'm scared that another one of my kids
is going to hate me and try to hurt
themselves again i need to put those
things on the table the word that nobody
likes to say especially tough guys
is vulnerable you have to say
you can hurt me with what i'm about to
tell you and i'm asking you not to
and what i'll tell you is this brian
you're going to feel comfortable
if you did all those three things
even you're going to take one one step
further if you read those two letters
that you wrote to nine year nine years
ago brian and uh three or four years ago
brian you read those to your wife
and then you sat down with her and had
this conversation
after all this then you can sit down and
you get to the point and say i don't
know what to do about your school
i'm harboring a lot of frustration and
anger
because i feel like you don't want to be
finished
and i feel like i've created a world
where you can't win
right
take ownership uh you've you know jocko
it like
my buddy jocko
yes like take ownership just take it
even if it's not all your take i'm gonna
take ownership of this
i'm gonna need to do some healing to
learn some new skills and
i'm gonna need us to dream together
and all of this is a completely
uncharted water for you this is you
walking out into the woods with a
machete you're saying i got a cart mount
i gotta cut my own path here gun what
i'm doing
but i will tell you this
being raged up and pissed off at your
wife will solve nothing other than
you not being married anymore
being pissed off and angry and raged out
will solve nothing other than your kids
will learn he's not safe to be around
and what i would say is look back on the
last 10 years and say has this has this
is this operating strategy worked in my
home the answer is no
so the true answer is okay i gotta do
something different
i'm taking a knee
i'm saying i'm sorry
hang on the line here i'm gonna send you
a copy of my new book i'm gonna send you
two things i'm gonna send you a copy of
my book and i'm sending the digital one
so you can listen to it in the car while
you're driving okay i'm gonna send you
an audio book and the new book own your
past change your future
my guess is brian if you and i talked
long enough we would go back to when
you're a kid because some of these
stories have been rattling around for a
long time
and what i'll tell you is you are too
good of a man
and you work too hard
and you love too deeply
to have this little peace in your life
to be this lonely to be this all by
yourself trying to hold this thing
together
and i'll give you the tools to start
healing that okay
i'm grateful for you appreciate you and
i gave you hell to begin this call i'm
not gonna apologize for it but i
appreciate you being honest and
going back and forth with me
i love you and i want you to have peace
in your life peace in your home and
peace in your family you deserve that
your kids deserve that your wife
deserves that
and the grandkids you've never met they
deserve that too